hey ich wollte mit euch heute über 123
ein paar themen auf jeden fall reden
weil es euch irritiert was da vorne
steht das sind lernen sachen und die
ganzen sachen von dem video days die
habe ich leider immer noch nicht alle
öffnen können heute kommt leider nur so
kurz ist kleines blog real live video
war ich heute klausur geschrieben habe
und ich werde die nächsten tage auch
noch mehrere klausuren schreiben dann
war ich heute noch klar sport spiel mit
peter und max und da bleibt leider nicht
mehr so viel zeit übrig bei youtube ist
auch schon viertel nach sechs ich wollte
fordert viertelstunde in der bibliothek
sein das heißt wir fangen jetzt einfach
mal mit dem ersten thema fanseiten auf
instagram twitter nutzt einer von euch
noch wirklich facebook ich habe
überhaupt nichts gegen fanseiten sie
kreativen content liefern und so weiter
und so fort aber manchmal geht es mir
tatsächlich ein bisschen zu weit das
meine ich jetzt auch überhaupt nicht
bezogen auf den fiction so oder so
obwohl ich's auch nicht so der fan von
bin aber einfach dass leute schreiben
luca volk mir oder ich bringe mich um
oder so was hab ich wirklich alles schon
lesen müssen oder jetzt auch letztens
was etwas größere fan seite gemacht hat
ich hab halt gefolgt und fand die bilder
super cool aber irgendwann fand ich dann
so ein paar aktionen einfach nicht mehr
so cool und ich fand die bilder nicht
mehr so klasse und dann bin ich halt
einfach and folgt das ein ganz normaler
beruf ist ich folge jemanden weil ich
den content feier den diese person macht
und wenn ich das nicht mehr fahre dann
hätte ich nicht rum sondern ich and
folge einfach allerdings hat der
betreiber bzw
die betreiberin der seite das ganze so
ein bisschen persönlich genommen und hat
da sind auch bilder gepostet so nein
wisst ihr was gestern passiert ist ich
will es gar nicht sagen aber ich bin
total fertig und ich weiß gar nicht was
ich jetzt machen soll
ich mache zwar noch weiter mit der seite
und ich denke mir nur so ich beziehe
mich da immer ganz gern auf france video
von damals wo er wirklich meinte hebt
mich nicht auf euer scheiß podest und es
ist wirklich einfach die wahrheit ich
bin auch ein ganz normaler mensch wie
wieso werde ich so als trophäe angesehen
so jo wenn er mir folgt ja das halten
wir fest in der instagram beschreibung
dann dann luca folgt das ist doch nichts
besonderes ich meine ich volk wir sind
alle nur menschen die kommen alle gut
miteinander klar
es muss doch nicht sein dass man sich
dann so blöd fühlt oder ich weiß nicht
ob ich der einzige bin der so denkt aber
ich sehe mich als jemanden der genau so
ist wie ihr und ich bin jetzt auch
niemand der sich irgendwie was auf seine
abonnenten oder in sein scheiß einbildet
und da kommen wir jetzt nämlich auch
schon weiter zum nächsten thema und zwar
die eine million abonnenten ja ich ja da
kurz vor bin diesen meilenstein zu
erreichen möchte ich euch nur schon mal
sagen nein es wird kein special kommen
und nein ich möchte auch auf keine bühne
und meinen riesige play button dann da
entgegennehmen weil ich einfach nicht so
ein typ bin jetzt unglaublich viel spaß
gemacht auf der gamescom auf der youtube
bühne darum zu handeln und mit euch zu
zocken und euch zu interagieren und mit
den t-shirts darum schmeißt und als es
beim mega cool aber wenn ich da oben
stehen müsste und ich würden preis
entgegen nehmen für das was ihr quasi
seit dann fühle ich mich dabei einfach
nur schlecht ich weiß nicht wann mein
letztes abo special kam aber es ist
definitiv schon länger als ein jahr her
oder irgendwie so weil ich einfach für
mich damals in meinem kompletten
persönlichkeit wandel die nicht mitte
2014 tatsächlich hatte da habe ich für
mich einfach festgehalten zahlen sind
einfach nur zahlen also ob ich da jetzt
mit 500.000 steht oder eine million oder
eine 3 an abonnenten dann sind es
einfach menschen dahinter und wenn das
ich weiß nicht über eine million mann
preis aber bei 999 1000 nicht nur weil
eine million siebenstellig wird wohl
trotzdem sind einfach nur menschen die
dazu kommen der einmillionste menschlich
abonniert ist quasi der mensch der für
mich diesen play button geholt hat sage
ich mal aber es ist ein mensch wie jeder
andere auch ich weiß nicht ob jeder
meinen gedanken weg so richtig
nachvollziehen können oder allgemein mit
mir be- einstand in der meinung weil
jeder der eigentlich eine million
abonnenten erreicht hat ist auf diese
bühne gegangen hat er seinen play button
who ich habe eine million abonnenten
und ich meine ich hab da auch nichts
gegen das einfach nur meine meinung dass
ich das einfach totaler schwachsinn
finde ich will einfach nicht auf eine
bühne und dann mit den play button
hochleben
schaut mich an ich hab eine million
abonnenten ich stehe über euch so keine
ahnung ich werde lieber und mit euch in
der masse und wird dann noch weiter
autogramme geben oder irgendwie so ich
finde das hat man auf dem video days
gemerkt wo ist einerseits die youtuber
gab die komplett im hintergrund
geblieben sind und wenn sie mal wohin
woods musste man sich die gültige normen
und irgendwie so da durchzukommen durch
die fanmassen und dann gab es andere
youtuber wie beispielsweise max oder
justin oder hotpants oder petrol oder
ich wo wir uns wirklich einfach zu den
leuten hingestellt haben und dann
wirklich da noch über das ende der video
days hinaus autogramme doch gegeben
haben ich will das jetzt überhaupt nicht
schlecht reden ist meine ich kann er
auch sein dass die youtuber dann
irgendwelche termine halten und schnell
dadurch mussten oder whatever aber ich
bin einfach mehr der typ ich stehe dann
lieber mit euch selbst unten drin
anstatt oben auf der bühne und ich
brauche nichts und komisches du hast
eine million abonnenten schild in meinem
zimmer ich mache den ganzen scheiß weil
es mir spaß macht und wenn mal drei tage
hintereinander kein video kam so wie
letztes dann hatte ich einfach keinen
bock auf dem video das ist der grund
warum ich nebenbei noch studiere damit
youtube für mich immer ein hobby bleibt
wenn ich einmal kein bock mehr hat dann
höre ich halt auf so einfach ist als ich
will mich dazu nicht zwingen die locals
wahrscheinlich nicht nachvollziehen und
natürlich verdiene ich damit auch mein
geld mehr oder weniger aber ich schweife
auch schon wieder total vom thema ab das
tut mir so leid kurze zusammenfassung
der sache es wird kein eine million abo
special kommen ich werde nicht irgendwie
meinen play button auf der bühne abholen
nächstes jahr auf den videos oder
gamescom oder so bin ich ihn nicht der
fan von es tut mir auch leid falls du
irgendwas erwartet habt oder so und an
alle fanseiten bitte seht mich nicht
krass als typ auf einem podest an so wie
kommt das wirklich schon gesagt hat ich
bin ganz normaler gut wie ihr auch und
ich hoffe wir sind alle cool metern
hinter ihr vorbei oder irgendwie so tut
mir leid dass ich meinen kanal mit
diesem video hier beschmutzen muss mehr
oder weniger das musste einfach mal raus
ist hatte sich angesammelt diese ganzen
sachen damit hört sich an als wäre das
irgendwie seine drogensucht die ich
hiermit gerade bekämpft hätte ich hoffe
ihr könnt meine meinung ein wenig
nachvollziehen
und wenn es euch gefallen hat würde ich
mich über eine bewertung freuen dann
sehen wir uns die nächsten tage in
irgendwelchen tollen gaming videos
wieder ciao